[Applause]
dalian atkinson was a star footballer
best known for his time at aston villa
he was 48 when he died
soon after being tasered and kicked in
the head by a police officer
pc benjamin monk is now on trial for
murder
his west mercier police colleague pc
mary ellen betley smith
on trial for assault they were called by
neighbors who'd heard mr atkinson
shouting outside his father's house in
telford
in the early hours in august 2016.
mr atkinson was unarmed but his behavior
was erratic
and he was claiming to be the messiah pc
monk fired his taser
three times twice it didn't work but the
third time
dalian atkinson fell forwards onto the
road
the prosecutor told the jury the
standard default setting of a taser is a
five-second phase
but it's possible to override that by
continuing to depress the trigger
pc monk continued to depress the trigger
for over six
times the length of a standard phase the
taser was deployed
for 33 seconds the court heard that
neighbours who were watching said once
dalian atkinson was on the ground he was
unresponsive and still
so no longer a threat to the officers
but they continued
pc betley smith struck him several times
with a bat
on and pc monk kicked him in the head at
least twice
so hard he left the imprint of his
shoelaces
on his forehead dalian atkinson died in
hospital
a short time later both pc monk
and pc betley smith deny all the charges
against them
their defense cases will be made in the
coming weeks
at the time of his death mr atkinson had
been suffering with serious health
conditions
including heart disease and end stage
renal failure
but the prosecution say their medical
experts believe were it not for the
taser deployment and kicks to his head
he would not have died that night becky
johnson
sky news birmingham